Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen was eine Variation was machst du
gerade
ich arbeite
ich genieße mein Leben unter blauem
Himmel sehr schön ja
ich habe ja wenig Zeit normalerweise
Romane zu lesen habe ich ja früher ganz
viel gemacht
und jetzt habe ich mir Zeit genommen das
neue Buch von tc-moll zur cool der der
war noch nicht in Berlin ne ja wann
wollte ich in Berlin
[Musik]
und ja da sind ja einer der größten
bedeutendsten lebenden Autoren der
Gegenwart aber so gut lesbar dass er
natürlich keine Nobelpreis gekriegt hat
und auch noch kein Schule Preis ein
Schicksal das hier teilt ganz ganz oben
gelegt
sehr sehr charmante ihm in ein Atemzug
genannt werden aber ja es ist einfach zu
gut für Preise aber der der der Roman
ist ist ein gutes Buch Richard ich weiß
nicht der der Einstieg ist immer so
spannende wie der erste Satz was ist der
erste Satz den ersten Satz weiß ich
gerade nicht weil ich mir eine Seite
rausgerissen habe okay ja um um das
jetzt vorzulesen
aber es fängt doch der erste Satz da
geht's darum dass eine Schlange gekauft
wird und dann wird erstmal nur
beschrieben ja wie das muss doch Geld
und das das ist wie Schmuck ist ja super
und erst anderthalb Seiten später
erfährt man das von einer Schlange die
Rede ist also großes Kino wunderbar
gemacht also die Kamera zeigt den
Großaufnahme könnte man jetzt sozusagen
aber genau nur die Textur direkt hier
richtig ja das gefällt mir klar
das ganze Buch ist ein Buch dazu gelogen
wie ein eine kalifornische Familie im
Zeitalter des Klimawandels vor sich hin
existiert
und das spielt nicht in der Zukunft
wieder alles spielt quasi in der
Gegenwart ja ja und erzählt quasi die
Allgegenwart des Klimawandels die so
klein und unmerklich ist und so nach und
nach in ein immer größeres
Katastrophenszenario führt und da will
ich dir was rausholen okay
und von der ist hier die Rede wir sind
jetzt auf Seite 35 also noch am Anfang
des Romans
utilie hatte beschlossen Insekten zu
essen weil ihr Sohn enthomologe war und
sie ihn liebte und weil es richtig war
anfangs hatte sie sich geweigert aber
Kuba hatte sie schließlich überzeugt der
Tod des Planeten das war sein Thema das
antrup Q10 dies witziges Homo sapiens
die ein Fluch war und so weiter die
Eisbären die Monarchfalter die frisch
der Planet stirbt siehst du das nicht
hatte er sie gefragt nein geradezu
angescht also das letzte Mal zum
Abendessen da gewesen war und seitdem
waren jetzt fast zwei Monate vergangen
genug Zeit um die Sache von allen Seiten
zu betrachten ja sie saß und sie fühlte
sich schuldig für den Anteil den sie
daran hatte in westlichen
Industriegesellschaften verbraucht jeder
Mensch 35 mal mehr Ressourcen als der
durchschnittliche Inder oder der
Afrikaner doch was konnte sie schon tun
außer Ihre Kreditkarten zu zerschneiden
und alles was ins Haus kam bis auf den
letzten Rest zu sein
mit dem letzteren hatte sie kein Problem
sie trennte den Müll ja ohnehin und
kompostierte den größten Teil der
organischen Abfälle das mit den
Kreditkarten war schwieriger denn man
muss ja Dinge kaufen um die Wirtschaft
in Schwung zu halten
also ließ sie sich ihre Kreditkarten
Abrechnung und alle anderen Rechnungen
papierlos übermitteln das war immerhin
ein Schritt den ich richtige Richtung
großartig es ist sozusagen du denkst
groß ja und am Ende kommt elektronische
Übermittlung Jahren
großartig und das finde ich ist eine
minutiöse Beschreibung dessen was gerade
auf dem Welttheater gespielt wird
also ich glaube eher dass die Menschen
sich an die ewige Abfolge von
Katastrophen im Zuge des Klimawandels
gewöhnen werden als wir es tatsächlich
schaffen das Steuer umzuweisen
und das ist eine ziemlich bedrückende
Einsicht unter blauem Himmel naja das
ist deswegen ja auch so interessant ich
meine ich weiß nicht ob du es
mitgekriegt hast am Wochenende also in
Deutschland tobt der heizkrieg ich ich
lese dir mal ein paar Schlagzeilen der
letzten Wochen von Bild vor Heiz Hammer
würde uns
590.000 € Kosten oder andere Schlagzeile
der heizhammer sprengt den Sozialstaat
der heizhammer ist eine Atombombe für
unser Land unsere Mieten werden
explodieren oder andere Schlagzeile
Wärmepumpen Muffin droht mega Strafe und
so weiter und ich denke dann immer
wahnsinn was macht das mit unseren
Gehirn wenn wir sowas lesen das ist
Wahnsinn die erste Frage ist warum macht
die Bild-Zeitung das
es geht ja darum im Grunde genommen
etwas umzusetzen das hat ja auch der
Altmaier bei dir in der Sendung unlängst
gesagt etwas umzusetzen was ja schon die
Vorgängerregierung ja die große
Koalition weiter beschlossen hat das ja
klar ist dass im Sinne des
klimaschutzgesetzes solche Dinge folgen
müssen ja das ist das ist ein total
interessanter Punkt wir haben das auch
noch mal sauber rausgearbeitet und
darüber geredet es ist egal auch wenn
Friedrich Merz Kanzler wäre er müsste
das machen ja ne er müsste das machen
und
ist da als grüne Ideologie und als
hätten irgendwelche merkwürdigen Spinner
sich der Macht bemächtigt so ja um den
den den kleinen Mann zu schicken genau
ich habe ich habe neulich einen sehr
interessantes Gespräch mit Maren Urner
gehabt die sich
medienwissenschaftlerin kennst du
bestimmt aus Köln die sagt diese Angst
getriebenen Diskussion das was da gerade
passiert das macht uns
dümmert und zwar deswegen weil wir aus
der Steinzeit kommen weil wir immer noch
so ein Steinzeit Gehirn haben ja wenn
wenn unser Gehirn in Angst versetzt wird
dann sinkt der IQ und zwar statistisch
signifikant wir werden blöder wenn wir
negative Nachrichten die ganze Zeit in
den Medien berieselt werden mit Angst
machende Nachrichten dann werden wir
dabei tatsächlich messbar neurologisch
dümmer das war mir nicht klar bei der
Bild-Zeitung die die ganze Zeit mit
solchen Material arbeitet ja dann
ziemlich breiten Einzug gehalten zu
haben wie dumm muss man als Redakteur
sein ja um hier in diesem Ausmaß mobil
zu machen haben die denn alle keine
Kinder
ich glaube das ist nicht das Thema
Richard und das ist hier geht ne ich
glaube also die die und ich würde den
auch nicht Dummheit unterstellen sondern
ich glaube es ist ein feines Gespür für
das was da draußen in dieser
Gesellschaft gerade passiert ich nenne
es dann ist null Gespür ist für das was
getan werden ja um das aller aller
schlimmste für die eigenen Kinder zu
verhindern ja aber was ich was ich meine
ist und da habe ich das Gefühl dass da
kommt man noch ganz schnell sozusagen
zum zu des Pudels Kern also machen Urner
sagt es gibt nachweislich es gibt es
gibt mehr auf mehreren Ebenen gibt es
ein Interesse daran dass zum Beispiel
Medien so sind wie sie sind ja sie sagt
es gibt sehr gut untersucht kann man
mittlerweile nachweisen wenn ihn
Überschriften möglichst negative Wörter
negative Gedanken negative
Tatsachen einfach auftauchen dann werden
die signifikant häufiger geklickt und
mit jedem einzelnen negativen Wort das
dort auftaucht noch mal um zwei bis drei
Prozent
musst du dir vorstellen das heißt die
Reaktion eines Medienschaffenden und das
wissen wir beide die Medienwelt ist
unfassbar unter Druck die großen Verlage
die privat Verlagswelt ist unglaublich
unter Druck und das Negative wir müssen
zu Geld wird
er erstmal eine Überschrift hin die
maximal negativ ist weil dann hat sie
eine Chance geklickt zu werden und
Überschriften die die deutlich positiver
sind werden einfach nicht geklickt das
klingt wie so eine banale Erkenntnis
sozusagen
die letzten 30 Jahren oder 40 Jahren
Mediengeschichte aber so ist es nicht
gemeint im im Zeitalter digitaler Medien
sagt sie ist es so dass das noch mal
unglaublich an Fahrt aufgenommen hat und
das hat was damit zu tun dass wir eben
dieses Steinzeit Gehirn besitzen das
unglaublich auf Angst reagiert weil
natürlich du kannst das bestimmt noch
viel besser erklären ein Gehirn dass das
sozusagen aufmerksam ist und immer
achten muss an welcher Ecke lauert der
Säbelzahntiger ja keine Kapazitäten
übrig hast Du in Ruhe über etwas
deswegen vom Ende her genau deswegen
macht es dich dümmer deswegen macht es
dich sozusagen im Grunde bist du was das
Denken angeht im Gehirn in einer
Sackgasse unterwegs aber es schützt Dich
auch gleichzeitig ne wenn wenn wir als
Menschen nicht die ganze Zeit sehr
aufmerksam gewesen wären was den
Säbelzahntiger angeht dann hätten wir
als Spezies nicht so lange überlebt aber
jetzt sind wir im 21 Jahrhundert und
haben diese diese diese digitale Welt
diese super modernen schnellen Werkzeuge
nur unser Gehirn ist nicht mitgekommen
und hat das nicht verstanden das ist ein
riesen Problem ja wir benutzen diese
Werkzeuge um unsere animals Spirits zu
bedienen genau richtig also unsere
tierischen Reflexe und alles das was uns
auch mit den Lebewesen Teil die nicht in
aller Ruhe über ihr Leben und die
Zukunft nachdenken können
aber nun sind wir ja historisch in einer
Situation 21 Jahrhundert zwanziger Jahre
des 21 jahrhunderts in der Situation
dass wir wissen dass die gesamte
Menschheit auf dem Spiel steht dass wir
langfristig planen müssen dass wir alle
zusammenarbeiten müssen was wir ganz
große Strategien brauchen weil sonst
alles den Bach runtergeht ich meine in
so einer Situation in aller erster Linie
jetzt so naheliegende Ängste zu führen
statt sich auf die wirklichen
Ängste zu konzentrieren also wovor muss
man mehr Angst haben vor Wärmepumpen ja
oder für vor vom global warming mit mit
Konsequenzen nicht nur die Insekten
plagen die dabei tief sie wollen eine
Rolle spielen sondern die gigantische
Migrationsbewegungen und so weiter
Themen die uns ja auch jetzt im
Augenblick beschäftigt ja die großen
Linie doch also man kann doch nicht
kleine Dinge die man als negativ
empfindet ganz ganz groß machen während
die richtig großen Bedrohungen die auf
die Menschheit hinzukommen wichtig ist
angenommen werden okay dann noch mal
Gegenargumente ich habe also in der
Sache völlig Recht und und auch
diejenigen die da sozusagen jetzt so
keifen und und die grüne Ideologie
Geiseln und so weiter nieder Ecke und
bei jeder Gelegenheit selbst die sagen
ja nicht da gibt es kein Problem die
sagen nicht da gibt es kein Thema mit
Klimaveränderung und die merken dass es
immer trockene wird der Kreuzfahrt
wieder gesehen dass wir schon wieder auf
Dürre zulaufen auch in Deutschland ich
dachte wir sind drei Wochen ja und und
und du merkst es wird häufiger und du
siehst wie die Gletscher abschmelzen wie
alle spüren dass der etwas gerade auf
einer völlig schiefen Bahn unterwegs ist
aber noch mal machen oder sehr
interessant und wieder die Medien also
wie alle die sagt am Beispiel Klima
Journalismus kannst du sehen was in der
Kommunikation an vielen Ecken schief
gelaufen ist es psychologisch sehr
interessant sagt da wurden auf lange
Zeit drei entscheidende Elemente
vernachlässigt
mit Menschen das Gefühl haben okay das
geht mich auch was an sagt also zeitlich
räumlich und sozial ne zeitliche Nähe
also es hieß immer naja da passiert
irgendwas in ein zwei drei vier
Jahrzehnten und sagt da auch da wieder
Steinzeit Gehirn unserem Gehirn fällt es
wahnsinnig schwer langfristig zu denken
und zu planen das können uns nicht
vorstellen dass das wollen muss auch
nicht vorstellen das interessiert uns
eigentlich nicht ja das andere ist die
räumliche und soziale Nähe räumliche du
erinnerst dich was ist sozusagen das das
was ist das dass das ikonographische
Motiv um Klimawandel zu zu dokumentieren
und zu demonstrieren in denk mal in die
Zeitungsberichte auch Fernsehen der
letzten Jahre und wirklich auch
Jahrzehnte werden genau der Eisbär auf
der Scholle exakt das ist aber räumlich
ne endlos ja weil Menschen finden Eisbär
süß wer tut einem Leid der tut uns leid
aber trotzdem ist es räumlich endlich
weit weg am Ende wächst dann doch die
Einsicht dass man sagt naja gut pass auf
ich sitze jetzt hier in Hamburg oder du
in Düsseldorf von wo auch immer bitte
wie weit ist es in die kanadische Arktis
ist eigentlich alles weit weg und dann
die die soziale Komponente ne also warum
berührt mich sagt sie eine Meldung dass
der Ozean wärmer wird und dass der
Meeresspiegel steigt warum berührt die
mich im ersten Moment in meinem tiefsten
Inneren ja also instinktiv im Gehirn
warum berührt die mich nicht und sie
sagt ganz einfach weil ich nicht im
Wasser lebe ja und dann kommt dazu so
das was sie nennt massive Lobbyarbeit
Händler des zweifelst nicht super also
die letzten Jahrzehnten einfach nur Zeit
damit verbracht haben Zweifel am an dem
zu sehen genau
die Fehlprognosen das klapp offroom und
das ist ja alles nicht so genau wie
angekündigt und so wer weiß und dann
irren die vielleicht doch alle richtig
keine letzten Sicherheiten und so dieser
ganze Quatsch
interessant finde ich ich meine das
Gegengift ne zu dem was da gerade von
Dir so genau geschrieben worden ist
Steinzeit Gehirn und so damit man sich
das vorstellen kann damit das nah an
einen rankommt ist TC Wolf zu lesen das
ist ja genau das was er macht er nimmt
eine ganz normale US-amerikanische
Durchschnittsfamilie und zeigt wieso
ganz klein ja diese diese Veränderungen
in der Atmosphäre ich meine Dürre in den
USA Hurricans
überschwemmungskatastrophen in Florida
das gibt es ja alles das ist ja alles da
Wirbelstürme und so weiter also die USA
sind ja viel stärker gebeutelt als
Deutschland bisher ne wir haben zwar
Teil Erlebnis gehabt aber das haben wir
auch schon wieder fast vergessen ja
stimmt das gab's ja auch ne das ist
schon gar nicht mit dem kollektiven
Bewusstsein drin aber wenn man das liest
also ich würde das zur absoluten
Pflichtlektüre machen dieses Buch und
zwar in Schulen ja und wie unter f
Politikern damit die sich das wirklich
mal so richtig vorstellen können was es
auch für sie am Ende bedeuten wird denn
das was sie am Beispiel von Kalifornien
beschrieben wird das ist nicht weit weg
von dem ja wie unser Leben in wenigen
Jahren aussehen könnte das macht also
dieses alles was du da gesagt hast wer
das arktische Eis ist weit weg und die
Ozeane und so weiter ja aber dieses
unterbrechen was macht das mit uns weißt
du bei der Wärmepumpe ist das ganz
einfach ja was weiß was das für dich
bedeutet was da für ein Geld auf dich
zukommt und weißt du wie brutal der
Staat mit dir umgeht wenn du das nicht
machst und so das kann man sich
vorstellen wir brauchen auf der gleichen
Ebene muss man sich einfach in die
Bild-Zeitung sich mal die Mühe machen
würde diese unmittelbaren spürbaren
Veränderungen durch den Klimawandel
richtig mal so Tag zu Tag zu Schlagzeile
zu machen dann hätte sie eine
konstruktive Aufgabe erfüllt aber ich
meine die Bild-Zeitung ist nie dazu da
gewesen konstruktive Aufgaben zu
erfüllen das muss man auch sagen
ich ich
wird das nicht nur in der Bild-Zeitung
festmachen das ist das ist ein
Geschäftsmodell von Medien insgesamt so
selbstkritisch müssen wir sein ne und
machen unerklärt das auch ganz genau
warum das so ist und sagt auch
interessant neulich in den standaten
super Interview gegeben wo sie sagt es
kann keinen objektiven Journalismus
geben den gibt es nicht es gibt kein
objektiven Journalismus sondern negative
Nachrichten werden deutlich mehr
geklickt da sitzen Menschen die die die
die wählen das dann aus und so weiter
und selbst wenn Menschen sagen in
Umfragen sie möchten mehr
lösungsorientierten Journalismus ja in
Wahrheit tendieren wir in stressigen
Situationen und Lebenslagen dazu noch
mehr auf negatives zu klicken ja und
werden sozusagen auf das zurückgeworfen
was unser Gehirn über ja hunderttausend
Jahre mittlerweile oder noch mehr
letzten Endes gelernt hat ja das ist der
Punkt und sie sagt die Kernaufgabe von
Journalismus und da bin ich jetzt bei
dir besteht eigentlich darin Menschen zu
informieren und handlungsfähig zurück zu
lassen ja sie besteht nicht darin
sozusagen unserem Steinzeit Gehirn
kurzfristig so diesen kleinen
aber wenn ich mir sie angucke was zum
Beispiel auch am Wochenende passiert ist
in Erding hast das mitgekriegt diese ja
diese Demonstration
monika Gruber wird da irgendwie durch
ihren Nachbarn glaube ich so habe ich
irgendwo gelesen aufmerksam und und sagt
ja es verstehe ich die Leute machen sich
Sorgen dass sie irgendwann ihre Heizung
nicht mehr bezahlen können und ihr Haus
nicht mehr halten können und dann
gezwungen sind das wofür sie ganzes
Leben lang hat gearbeitet haben zu
veräußern die Plane Demo sie sagt ich
mache mit dann lädt Sie Markus Söder ein
der kommt auch und plötzlich kriegt das
Ding eine irrsinnige Dynamik ja was da
am Wochenende passiert ist und dann
kommt Hubert eiwanger
der bayerische Wirtschaftsminister und
und kriegt Tosen in Applaus an einer
sehr interessanten Stelle und zwar an
der Stelle an der sagt Ansage an alle
Medien stellt euch endlich mal wieder
auf die Seite der kleinen Leute
der Jubel hört gar nicht mehr auf und
ich wollte dich mal fragen wie du so
etwas findest also gibt man kann
sozusagen ganz viele Perspektiven
einnehmen es gibt es gibt die eine
Fraktion die sagt geht alles gar nicht
da da da da da da waren auch afdler das
war eine unter anderem auch eine
kleinere AFD Kundgebung und so weiter
und dann werden sofort alle wieder zu
Nazis und rechtsradikalen gemacht das
ist mir viel zu weit und viel zu heftig
sondern ich finde Menschen haben das
Recht ihren Unmut zu äußern Menschen auf
die Straße zu gehen und auch wütend zu
sein wenn Ihnen irgendetwas nicht passt
also dass die dann alle gleich so wieder
über einen Kamm zu scheren und einfach
alle zur rechtsradikalen zu erklären
greift zu kurz aber er stellt sich da
oben hin und sagt und ich denke die
ganze Zeit Richard über diesen Satz nach
weil wir beide ja auch mit Medien immer
zu tun haben teils als Objekt teils als
Subjekt ja total wird über uns berichtet
teils machen wir es selber
stellt euch endlich wieder auf die
richtige Seite ich habe das ganze
Wochenende über diesen Satz nachgedacht
und habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt hat
der da der Aiwanger einen
wahren Kern getroffen
was willst du sagen
die Sache ist ja was ist denn die sich
der kleinen Leute ja das unterstellt ja
dass die kleinen Leute sich einig sind
ja und das ist eine Sicht der kleinen
Leute gibt und ich würde sagen bei dem
Thema und das ist ja da am Ende geht
beim Klimawandel gibt es die sich der
kleinen Leute nicht
sondern es gibt ein Gefühl ne ja hier
gibt's ein Gefühl die da oben guten uns
etwas zu sichern die da oben wollen dass
wir bestimmte Dinge machen die wir nicht
einsehen so das kann ich irgendwo
nachvollziehen und das haben wir auf der
anderen Seite das Problem wenn wir beim
Klimawandel darauf warten bis jeder
einzelne alles bis zum geht nicht mehr
eingesehen hat und bereit ist ein ganzes
Leben zu ändern dann brauchen wir gar
nicht weiter darüber nachzudenken
das heißt also wir sind in der
schwierigen Lage dass der Staat daraus
Vorgaben zu machen und zwar egal welche
Regierung was wie wo beschlossen hat ne
also hier Klimaschutzziele die sind ja
damals formuliert worden nachdem das
Bundesverfassungsgericht festgestellt
hat ja dass wir die rechte künftiger
Generationen mit einem berücksichtigen
müssen bei der Politik die wir heute
machen genau das wäre also mit anderen
Worten nicht so weitermachen können dass
wir die Zukunft für unsere Kinder vor
frühstücken richtig da kann man nicht
warten bis jeder das eingesehen also der
der Punkt ganz ganz man muss immer
Aufklärungsarbeit machen alleine im
kommenden Jahren ne müssen in
Deutschland vier Millionen Heizungen
ausgetauscht werden und zwar weil sie
dann 30 Jahre alt werden das ist nichts
was sich der böse Robert habe oder Olaf
Scholz oder irgendjemand ausgedacht hat
sondern das ist schon lange Pflicht
richtig das ist schon lange Pflicht also
weißt Du man kann das kritisieren ne mir
fallen auch Argumente einen mit denen
man das kritisieren kann ich ernst nehme
also wir schauen nach Dänemark und wir
sehen was bauen die ein
wärmepumpenkraftwerk
das ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Sache
als jedem Einzelnen zu sagen hört man du
musst aber jetzt hier deine Heizung da
geht in Zukunft nicht mehr und dann
sehen wir zu wie du dorthin Christ also
die Frage ist setzen wir an der genau
richtigen Stelle ein andererseits muss
man sagen in dem gleichen Dänemark ist
das was wir heute machen ja der
Austausch und wie wärmepumpeneinführung
schon vor zehn Jahren passiert 20
hat sich darüber aufgeregt
wir neigen natürlich dazu diese Sachen
zu instrumentalisieren ja unter anderem
eben die CSU ja die gleiche Partei die
dieses Klimaschutzgesetz das hier
umgesetzt wird unterschrieben hat
gemacht hat
ich meine das geht überhaupt nicht wir
können uns dieses Getränk in diesen
Fragen doch nicht leisten ja aber ja er
sind mir ist völlig unklar wie jemand
wie wie Markus Söder ja über den ich
auch Positives sagen könnte wieso der
sich in dieser Situation wirklich zum
Sprecher von diesem Mumpitz zu machen
ich habe eine Idee ich als muss Grenzen
des Populismus geben ja das ist das ist
aber wer definiert diese Grenzen des
Populismus ist es ist es nicht in
Ordnung wenn ein also es war ketzerische
these Richard Söder hat Wahlen in diesem
Jahr vor der Brust und es geht um
einiges und du siehst ja auch was
passiert wenn man sozusagen Dinge
einfach
nicht ernst nimmt wenn man wenn man
dieses Gefühl so laufen lässt die da
oben gegen uns da unten die nehmen uns
nicht ernst und du weißt in den
Thüringen steht ein ein Landrat von der
AFD kurz vor der absolut Mehrheit kurz
vor der absoluten Mehrheit das ist die
Situation in der wir sind wollen wir das
oder ist mir dann vielleicht einer wie
Söder der dann auch mal den
populistischen Ausfallschritt macht und
sagt ah ich habe mein Ohr immer sehr
sehr nah dran an dem was die Leute so
denken und reden und das gleiche gilt
dafür Hubert awanger und und dann und
dann bediene ich das jetzt mal bis zu
einem bestimmten Punkt bist dann
bestimmten Punkt finde ich müssen
Politiker sogar ja den haben wir auch
schon darüber gesprochen die Frage ist
wer definiert diese Grenze wo ist diese
Grenze weil es zu nichts konstruktiven
führt findest du dass ich ich ich ich
würde mal unterscheiden es gibt mit
Sicherheit konstruktiven Populismus ja
und destruktiven Populismus und hier
geht es einfach darum zu sagen wollen
wir nicht und die bevormunden uns und
was weiß ich was und so weiter so jetzt
hätte ich gerne von Markus Söder und für
dein Aiwanger Geld gewusst ja wie sie
die Klimaschutzziele umsetzen wollen man
kann bei dem was das
Wirtschaftsministerium da macht und so
weiter sicherlich an vielen Punkten
Kritik äußern da habe ich auch überhaupt
gar kein Problem mit ich finde insgesamt
dass wir beim Klimawandel viel zu
kleinteilig Vorgehen ja dass wir viel zu
wenig große internationale Projekte
machen das wäre viel zu sehr nationale
Strategien manchmal nur regionale
Strategien verfolgen am Ende soll dann
dabei rauskommen dass ich alle an
Deutschland ein Vorbild nehmen das ist
so eine lieblingsformulierung der Grünen
ne das ist wunderbar wir schaffen die
Energie und Somalia und Nigeria und
Brasilien nehmen sich alle ein Vorbild
an Deutschland also mir fehlt viel zu
sehr die die globale Perspektive das
kann man alles kritisieren aber wenn ich
jetzt Populist bin und sagt das will ich
alles nicht haben und ich will nicht
beworben und nett werden dann möchte ich
von Söder ganz konstruktive alternative
Ideen haben wie wir unsere
Klimaschutzzielen und das muss in der
gleichen Rede vorkommen ja ich kann also
schimpfen und sagen das mit den
Wärmepumpen und so weiter und das geht
nicht und das ist einer falschen Stelle
angesetzt sondern es ist zu teuer und es
belastet die falschen aber dann muss ich
erzählen ja wie man das alles viel
besser machen kann und dieser Bereich
fehlt ja ich ich finde ja ich hatte ein
Problem mit einem anderen Satz und und
das ist so der Moment wo wo einem
wirklich Angst und Bange wird also dass
das eine ist Hubert ein langer noch mal
ja diese diese Rede die die mit Dosen
immer Applaus begleitet wurde der sagte
und das ist so ein Bierzelt und es ist
alles in Ordnung ja die in Berlin die
sind alle doof und so weiter und die
kenn en sich da nicht aus und die machen
nur Mist von morgens bis abends und hier
stehen aber die guten die anständigen
Leute die von morgens bis abends
arbeiten und die wollen das Eltern Mama
und Papa sind und nicht irgendwas
dazwischen und die Fleisch essen und die
wollen auch in Urlaub fahren und so
weiter so weit der ganze ja das ist und
das ist auch alles in Ordnung aber dann
sagt er den Satz wir holen uns jetzt die
Demokratie zurück
und dann das ist sehr nach dem AFD so
das klassischer okay da verrutscht uns
gerade etwas und da kommt es plötzlich
so ein Sound rein der wirklich nicht gut
ist und ich frage mich dann immer ist
das eine der Gründe weil wir uns
mittlerweile so dermaßen verkämpfen ich
meine das ist ein falsches wir von dem
hier die Rede ja
ist erstmal wird unterstellt es sei die
Mehrheit ja zum Beispiel und dann muss
man ganz vorsichtig sein dieses wir das
für die AFD ja auch immer sagt ne die
spricht ja auch immer von hier ja und
die AFD ist keine Mehrheit und da muss
man immer sehr sehr vorsichtig sein wenn
man ein wir instrumentalisiert von dem
man unterstellt es wäre quasi die
schweigende Mehrheit gegen die regiert
wird wenn aber die Wahlergebnisse etwas
anderes zeigen dann kann man dieses via
nicht in dieser Form benutzen
richtig das klingt ja auch so als hätte
eine Bande von Verbrechern quasi das
Land gekapert ja total die nicht die
nicht gewählt worden ja es ist auch
schwierig zu sagen hier sind die guten
und die anständigen Leute und so zu tun
als wären in Berlin keine guten unter
anständige Leute ne das ist ja auch alle
Leute in Bayern
genau das wird auch selbst in Bayern
niemals sagen aber aber interessant ist
sozusagen der der der Sound der da
plötzlich reinkommt und dieses
unversöhnliche und ich ich du weißt dass
der der Kampf gegen diese wärmewende
überall auf der Welt werden jetzt
entscheidende Maßnahmen
ergriffen weil man verstanden hat wie
wir müssen da etwas tun und den nur in
Deutschland und interessanterweise in
England wird der Kampf so hart und
ideologisch geführt dass man das Gefühl
hat die Wärmepumpe ist jetzt wirklich
das Ding an dem sich das Schicksal der
gesamten Menschheit entscheidet
wahrscheinlich bei dem was du ich habe
den Eindruck dass du die ganze Zeit so
ein bisschen darauf hinaus willst doch
mit dem was du vorhin gefragt hast
geht es bei der Wärmepumpen Diskussion
und Wärmepumpen ja das ist genau der
Punkt eben nicht das ist ja das was du
mit dem mit dem iwanger Beispiel erklärt
hast es geht um es geht um einen
Kulturkampf richtig und der sich an der
Wärmepumpe entzündet ja und man hat
schon eine schöne Freundin leider leider
aus meiner Sicht trage ich ja weil ich
könnte die wenn dieser Kulturkampf an
solchen Dingen entzündet an denen er
sich auch entzündet wie am Gendern oder
sowas alles ja dann hat das am Ende
keine großen Konsequenzen ja also ob man
am Ende dann in 10 oder 20 Jahren alles
gendert oder nichts mehr gendert oder so
ist ehrlich gesagt eine emotional
vielleicht im Augenblick interessante
Frage ja aber langfristig ist es völlig
egal ist richtig aber die Frage ob wir
die Energiewende schaffen oder nicht die
ist überhaupt nicht egal ja hier geht es
auch nicht um darum dass man dieses
Beispiel nimmt um jetzt ökologische
Politik zu blockieren das sind extrem
dämlich aufs Feld um ein wir gegen die
aufzum achen
und das nervt mich schon ziemlich daran
weil der Ernst der Lage ist viel zu groß
als dass man sich in diesem Blödsinn
verkämpft das andere ist diesen Riss
gibt es also diesen Riss wir kriegen ja
ich habe manchmal wollte ich es nicht
glauben ne aber wir kriegen ja jeden
Scheiß der in Amerika schief läuft 510
Jahre später bei uns ist absolut so ja
und dieses schimpfen auf die politischen
Eliten mit den Donald Trump äh sein
Wahlkampf gewonnen hat ja und wo man
auch sagen muss ja das stimmt natürlich
nicht diese Eliten in Washington die
leben in einer völlig anderen Welt ja
als ein Pharma in Kentucky oder ein ein
Stahlarbeiter in Cincinnati das ist ja
richtig die leben wirklich in einer
komplett so und da gibt es auch Lobbys
ja wie zum Beispiel Finanzlobby und so
die unglaublich einflussreich sind und
die sich überhaupt nicht für den Farmer
in Kentucky interessiert das ist auch
alles richtig aber das sind so eine
grundsätzliche Haltung gemacht hat das
Volk ja gegen seine korrupten Eliten
dass also ein Bild produziert wird das
klassisch ist für gangsterländer ja also
ein großer Teil der Länder dieser Welt
werden von korrupten Eliten regiert und
das Volk ist egal dass man aber eine
liberale Demokratie wie Deutschland ja
sukzessive damit gleichsetzt und sagt
wir sind auch so ein Land ja wo ist
korrupte Eliten gibt und ideologische
Spinner und die da irgendwie scheiße
durchsetzen wollen auf Kosten der
Bevölkerung das ist eigentlich ein
US-Import ich habe ja mal was
geschrieben über die AFD dass sie aus
zwei Bestandteilen besteht die nicht
zusammenpassen das eine ist also dieses
was wir gerne Nazi nennen also dieser
dieser extreme Deutschland Nationalismus
bis hin zu echten Nazis ja sehr sehr
deutsch den den ist Deutschland nicht
deutsch genug ja und wenn die an
Deutschland denken dann denken die an
Deutschland vor 45 oder Deutschland
Kaiser Wilhelms Zeiten oder wie auch
immer und das andere das sind diese
Palio Liberalen die so dieses Mal Pony
my Reifen wie ja Start halt dich raus
ich will meine Freiheit ich will dass
ich niemand in mein Leben einmischt ich
will mich nicht von irgendeiner
Obrigkeit Gängen lassen ich will am
liebsten auch keine Steuern zahlen und
so weiter und die beiden Dinge sind
totale Widersprüche das erste will den
starken Start der alles bestimmt und das
zweite will den schlechtes möglichen
Staat der am besten gar nicht existiert
genau ja
Verteidigung organisiert und die Polizei
ja diese alte Ronald reagansatz ne wenn
wenn wenn bei Ihnen zu Hause ein Mann
hat die Tür klopft und sagt guten Tag
ich bin vom Staat dann mach sofort
wieder zu und und und verbarrikadiere
dich in deiner Bude weil das bedeutet
nichts Gutes der Staat ist sozusagen der
Dämon der nur Geld verschwendet der nix
auf die Reihe kriegt und der der
sozusagen deine mühsame Arbeit wieder zu
nicht gemacht genau das ist das Palio
liberale oder paleolibertäre und beides
ist in der AFD ineinander vermischt und
mal kommt das eine raus und mal kommt
das andere raus ja also in der
Migrationsfrage kommt das erste raus ja
und in der Ökologie Frage kommt das
zweite raus ohne dass den Menschen in
dem Moment bewusst sind dass sie zwei
Widersprüche oder ein Widerspruch so in
ihrem Bewusstsein speichern ja dass die
Einzelteile dort nie Zusammentreffen das
ist überhaupt kein in sich geschlossenes
Weltbild sondern es ist immer in
Gegenwelt richtig
und das ist das große Problem was diese
Partei hat und der große Vorteil gegen
diese Partei hat ist dass ihn immer mehr
Leute zulaufen und ich glaube diese 18%
19,5 %. aber warum ein Söder sich
hinstellt und dieses wir gegen die
bedient denn das nützt am Ende nicht der
CSU das wird am Ende der AFD nutzen und
deswegen halte ich das dann ganz großen
Fehler was er da gemacht hat
ich bin mir da wirklich nicht sicher das
ist ja das was ich fühlte mich an
Michael Kretschmer erinnert der ja auch
jemand ist der der da einen sehr harten
Fight kämpft und zwar schon die ganze
Zeit und ich
glaube man muss anfangen auch wirklich
auf bestimmte Argumente einzugehen man
wir müssen zur Kenntnis nehmen äh das
auch wir medial müssen zu Kenntnis
nehmen dass viele Menschen das Gefühl
haben wir bilden sie gar nicht mehr
wirklich ab wir sind viel zu weit von
den entfernt wir wir überfordern dieses
Land und und wenn wir wenn die Leute
dann überfordert sind und sagen dass das
passt mir jetzt aber alles nicht also
mal gucken alles alles so
rechtsradikales verstehen die alles
nicht und dann wollen sie auch noch
Fleisch essen oder Nacken so geht's
nicht weiter ich habe dieser Tage in
einem interessanten Buch gelesen Michael
kennst du bestimmt natürlich genau ähm
berühmter amerikanischer Philosoph
angeblich der Lieblings Philosoph von
von Olaf Scholz das Unbehagen in der
Demokratie und der sagt in diesem Buch
auch sinngemäß und beschreibt das auch
sehr genau
dass ich in den demokratischen
Gesellschaften hat sich eine enorme
Unzufriedenheit angesammelt und sehr
viele Menschen vor allem aus den
Arbeiterklassen haben das Gefühl dass
sie nicht wirklich beachtet werden ja
zusammen schon häufig besprochen und er
sagt irgendwie auf die Frage wie das
eigentlich sein kann weil eigentlich
haben wir doch eine prosperierende
Situation eigentlich geht's uns doch gut
wir haben historisch niedrige
Arbeitslosigkeit wir haben global
betrachtet deutlich zunehmenden
Wohlstand und er sagt ja aber nicht für
alle gleichermaßen die kämpfen gerade da
draußen unfassbar diese genau diese
ganze Mittelschicht und Arbeiterklasse
und er sagt wir haben viel zu lange und
diesen internationalen Finanzströmen
also sozusagen dem Kult des Geldes
geholtigt ja und der hat diese geteilten
Gesellschaft von Gewinnern und
Verlierern hervorgebracht und das können
wir uns schlicht und ergreifend nicht
mehr leisten und der und ist von Jahr
interessant er sagt da gibt es so ein
Hochmut da drin sagt diese Elite hat der
auch noch gerne so dieses Gefühl und das
das Verbreiten die dann auch und sagen
naja also wir sind die wir strengen uns
an wir verdienen für euch alle mit die
Kohle wir zahlen die großen steuern und
jetzt benehmt euch mal bitte und dieses
Gefühl dieser Hochmut ja sich sozusagen
im eigenen Erfolg zu ergötzen das fällt
uns gerade auf die Füße weil dabei
völlig vergessen wird und das Vergessen
auch die wie viele Menschen dazu
beitragen ja also wenn Jeff Bezos sagt
ich zahle unvorstellbar viele Steuern
oder Elon Musk dann vergiss da meistens
zu erwähnen wie unvorstellbar viele
Menschen in seinem riesigen laden dazu
beitragen dass er dieses viele Geld
verdient und dass er diese vielen
Steuern zahlt aber ich finde zu dem Kern
was bei der sendel Analyse nicht
vorkommt weil das ist ja eine klassische
in Amerika würde man sagen liberale
Analyse von uns würde man sagen linke
Analyse
ja die dann einfach darin besteht und
und sagt dieser ganze Deal unserer
Gesellschaft der geschieht auf Kosten
von abgehängten und von auch von einer
wachsenden Zahl von abgehängten es gibt
einen Punkt habe ich noch nie gelesen
dass der eigentlich mal thematisiert
worden ist und der erklärt warum das so
ein Problem ist es ist ja klassisch
nicht ein Problem dass eine Gesellschaft
viele abgehängte hat das war ja immer so
erzähl mir mal von einer Gesellschaft in
die jetzt nicht viele abgehängte gibt in
der Schweiz vielleicht oder Luxemburg
aber das ist ein großer Zahl von Leuten
gibt die politisch unter repräsentiert
sind ja also einfachen Arbeiter ja
Arbeitslose und so weiter ne wie viel
Arbeitslose gibt es im Bundestag ne wie
viel Lobbyisten haben die da die sich
für sie einsetzen und so weiter also das
ist normal aber etwas hat sich verändert
in den letzten 10 15 Jahren unter
anderem beschleunigt durch die sozialen
Netzwerke dass die abgehängten ein
anderes Selbstbewusstsein haben als
früher und dass sie den Anspruch stellen
nicht mehr abgehängt sein zu wollen das
ist historisch neu
der allergrößte Teil auch der Arbeiter
egal ob es Gewerkschaften gab und
Arbeiterbewegungen ja war unpolitisch
war gewohnt ja das auf dem kleinen Mann
sowieso keiner hört und dass die da oben
egal ob das jetzt demokratisches System
war oder im Monarchie oder was auch
immer die Diktatur machen was sie wollen
dass Sie also sowieso nicht gehört
werden heute leben wir in einer
Gesellschaft und das kann man erstmal
positiv beschreiben ja in der jeder
gehört werden will
und ich könnte die ketzerische these
Wagen dass unsere Demokratien darauf
nicht vorbereitet sind ist richtig ja
wir kriegen dann keine
Konsensgesellschaft mehr hin genau wenn
also diejenigen die normalerweise die
Verlierer in der Gesellschaft sind
meistens weitgehend ruhig war und die
waren in der Bundesrepublik schon
deswegen ruhig weil die Verlierer immer
noch sagen dass es auch den Verlierern
im Prinzip von Jahr zu Jahr besser
gegenüber eine lange Zeit
ne also 50er 60er 70er Jahre und so
weiter 80er Jahre zum großen Teil noch
ja in Relation zwei armer geworden aber
die Faktor konnten sich immer mehr
leisten
so und die hatten aber sehr lange kein
politisches starkes Selbstbewusstsein
und das haben wir heute und man kann
sagen dass die AFD ist es schafft vielen
abgehängten politische Selbstbewusstsein
zu geben ja und das ist sehr interessant
und das ist sozusagen macht die AFD zu
einem ganz wichtigen soziologischen
Phänomen ich will immer was sagen ich
mache das jetzt auch schon ein paar Tage
15 Jahre haben wir gerade gefeiert ja
unsere Sendung ich allein der Satz und
und da kommen wir doch jetzt noch mal zu
dem Thema aber das wäre auch heute unter
anderem reden wollten wie verkämpfen uns
dann die Gräben werden tiefer und tiefer
die Fronten immer verhärteter wir können
uns auf nichts mehr einigen und wir sind
nicht mehr in der Lage ernsthafter mal
unsere Zukunft und das was wichtig ist
für uns wirklich in den Blick zu nehmen
der Satz wir brauchen in der
migrationskrise zum Beispiel brauchen
wir eine europäische Lösung
diesen Satz den habe ich ich weiß nicht
habe ich den 3000 mal gehört oder 4000
mal oder 5000 Mal noch zweiten Satz den
würde ich gerne daneben stellen aber
welchen also das eine ist wir brauchen
einen europäische Lösung ja was am Ende
heißt es passiert nichts anderes als das
irgendwelche
grenzschutztruppen vergrößert werden und
und und Zäune größer gemacht ja das ist
ja das ist das eine das läuft ja immer
darauf hinaus also es läuft immer auf
defensive Strategien nie auf proaktive
Strategien hinaus und damit direkt
verbunden es gab einen Satz in dieser
ganzen migrationsdiskussion 2015 ist 8
Jahre her ne als als die Leute aus
Syrien kamen und dann die große
flüchtlingskrise kam da gab es Einsatz
da man sich alle einig wenn man den in
der Rede machte kriegt man immer Beifall
egal wer den und das war wir können
nicht alle aufnehmen
wir müssen die Fluchtursachen bitte
richtig jetzt würde ich gerne mal von
dir wissen Markus welche Fluchtursachen
haben wir die letzten acht Jahren
bekämpft ja genau die haben keine aktive
proaktive Offensive Flüchtlingspolitik
gemacht sondern eine rein Defensive
Flüchtlingspolitik wo man sich
wechselseitig ja du übernimmst und du
musst die aber neben nee will ich nicht
nimm du die und so ja klein klein klein
klein und außer Grenzen schützen und
besser schützen ja ist am Ende fast
nichts passiert man hat acht Jahre alt 8
Jahre alt ist eine riesen lange Zeit
gehabt und was gegen Fluchtursachen zu
tun
und die Folgen des Klimawandels ja also
Vergrößerung der der ariden Gebiete der
Wüstengebiete in Afrika ja der mit all
dem was dazu führt zu kriegen instabilen
Regierungen migrationsbewegung und so
weiter wir machen so gut wie überhaupt
nicht
und es wäre so viel günstiger das zu
machen weil wir können unsere Grenzzäune
noch so hoch machen und wir können noch
so viel Patrouillen Boote irgendwohin
schicken wir werden uns auf einen
bestimmten Punkt gegen gigantische
migrationsbewegung nicht schützen können
wir sind unser eigenes eigenen
Fortbestandes will enorm gezwungen uns
an die Fluchtursachen anzumachen und ich
habe immer das Gefühl ich weiß das ja
nicht ich arbeite hier nicht in so einem
Ministerium aber würde doch denken man
muss langfristig planen man muss
proaktiv planen man muss europäisch
konzertiert planen ich habe schon auch
bei diesen ökosachen immer das Gefühl
jeder kocht sein eigenes Süppchen ja da
gibt's natürlich Geld von der
Europäischen Union für dieses Projekt in
Marokko gibt Geld und für dieses das
Projekt in der Nordsee gibt es ein
bisschen Geld und in dem kleinen Projekt
arbeiten die drei Länder zusammen und da
die fünf ich meine bei dem Ernst der
Lage müsste man doch eigentlich ein
Masterplan machen und müsste sagen wo
können wir die meiste Windenergie
herbekommen
wo in der Sahara könnten wir genug
Sonnenenergie abschöpfen und so weiter
also all diese Sachen müssen noch mit
großer Hand geplant werden und genau in
dem gleichen Maße eben auch die
Bekämpfung der Fluchtursachen passiert
alles nicht hier reagieren ja das ist
wahr anderes Beispiel aber du erinnerst
dich an dieses ich fand das damals so
fasziniert deshalb absolut ich war
begeistert als ich dachte die Idee
sozusagen erzähl mal kurz was die Idee
war Richard ja der die Idee war dass sie
viele Firmen international zusammen tun
ja um Solarenergie aus der Sahara zu
gewinnen genau das war die Idee dahinter
also Wüsten
ne also da haben sich intellektuell
zusammengesetzt und haben auch eine
super Idee und dann gab es auch viele
deutsche Firmen die sich daran beteiligt
haben und gesagt hat das ist in der Tat
eine super Idee und dann passierte das
erste war natürlich das Problem muss es
ja wahnsinnig viele Leitungen machen um
das ganze irgendwie übers Mittelmeer
rüberzubringen ziemlich große
Investition und das zweite war das dann
Stimmen laut wurden innerhalb dieses
Konsortiums die gesagt haben naja sollen
wir jetzt da aus der Sahara den ganzen
Strom dazu uns abziehen wenn man sich
mal guckt wie die
Entwicklungsperspektiven von Marokko und
Algerien und Ägypten und so weiter
aussehen da gibt's ja auch immer mehr
Menschen und da wird es auch
Wirtschaftswachstum und sowas gibt die
brauchen ja auch für sich schon ja
brauchen die ja andere Energiequellen
das heißt die brauchen den Solarstrom ja
auch erstmal selber genau so und dann
gab es nicht eine Fraktion die gesagt
wir machen das Ganze ja nur weil wir in
Europa das nutzen wollen und die andere
Fraktion die gesagt hat nee lass uns das
lieber erstmal für die Länder dort
aufmachen dann hat man nicht zerstritten
und dann gab es für dieses ganze Projekt
ja innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch
keinerlei für Agenda ich vermute jetzt
nach kurzester Zeit haben wir natürlich
EU etwas sowieso glaube ich meines
Wissens jedenfalls nicht gefördert
Bundesregierung hat sich da relativ früh
rausgezogen und so dabei ist ja der
Gedanke faszinierend ja zu sagen hey du
ich weiß nicht wie wie klein die Fläche
in der Sahara sein müsste ja es gibt ja
viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten wie man
solaren Energie nutzen kann aber du
brauchst relativ wenig Fläche die
komplett unbewohnt ist die eigentlich
keiner zu Gesicht kriegt und kannst also
enorme Mengen saubere Energie erzeugen
ja wenn wenn man muss sich nur mal klar
machen ne dass die die Energie die die
Sonne jeden Tag zu uns auf die Erde
schickt ist ein sigraches dessen was wir
an Strom an Energie tatsächlich brauchen
das musst du dir mal vorstellen also wir
haben eigentlich ist sozusagen der Traum
der endlosen günstigen Energie den
könnten wir tatsächlich Realität werden
lassen ja die ganze Diskussion die wir
hier haben über Landschaft Verspargelung
und Überleitung und so weiter die hätten
wir dann nicht mehr ja wenn wir es
woanders erzeugen würden das war ja
sozusagen die Vision dahinter genau und
es ist erstaunlich dass das zum Beispiel
nie ein großes europäisches Projekt
geworden richtig dass man Ruhe zugeguckt
hat wie man sich da verzankt hat ja ich
meine es ist was von übrig geblieben ne
es gibt ja ein mehreren Vorzeigeprojekte
dass meine mehreren arabischen Staaten
wollte gerade sagen nur Projekt in
Marokko genau wo ja schon schon
ordentlich was passiert ist aber hier
ist wieder das selber auch die Deutschen
haben da gefördert ja aber dann wird
hier für 36 Millionen Mal die
Versuchsanlage und dann wird diesmal das
sind 36 Millionen überleg mal ich meine
das kostet so viel wie viel große Willen
auf Mallorca
okay okay
verzweifelt dass diese dass sie
Zusammenarbeit nicht funktioniert das
seitdem dass wir immer das können wir
sagen ja und da investiert die Firma mal
das und da gibt es den Fördertopf und
dann kann man mal gucken was man da so
machen kann das klingt alles so als
hätten die alle nicht von dir
mitgekriegt worüber TC Bolzen im Buch
ich ich bin mir ja ich ich frage mich
manchmal sind wir das alle oder sind nur
wir das also mein Blick ist eher der ich
wir haben oft darüber gesprochen ne dass
wir damals 216 das erste Mal in Amerika
ich jetzt für mich persönlich wirklich
wahrgenommen habe ja
George Packard das Buch dazu geschrieben
die anwending ja die Abwicklung wenn man
das mal liest der kriegst du heute noch
Gänsehaut war genauso ist es eingetreten
aber jetzt gehen die Amerikaner hin
machen ganz pragmatisch
Inflation reduction Act und sind selbst
überrascht über diesen riesigen Erfolg
es gibt keine nennenswerte Firma auf der
Welt kein globales Unternehmen von
Siemens Energy bis hin zu vielen anderen
die nicht jetzt gerade ankündigen in
Amerika in grüne Technologie zu
investieren in diesem wir alle dabei ja
wir machen das natürlich wieder viel
kleiner und so
da ist Europa kein Zug drin die sind
total gut mit Zahlen ja so zahlen wo man
sagt ja in 30 Jahren wollen wir Klima
neutral sein das finde ich super wenn
Ursula von der Leyen sagt mal sehen die
200050 oder so ist Europa Klima neutral
2050 ist sie nicht mehr
kommissionspräsidentin und 2015 lebt sie
möglicherweise auch gar nicht mehr also
warum diese fernhorizonte war Malen von
etwas wofür man nie wieder zur
Verantwortung gezogen wird warum nicht
zu sagen in zwei Jahren wollen wir da
sein in vier Jahren wollen wir da sein
in sechs Jahren wollen wir das geschafft
haben wenn man das macht so kleinteilige
Sachen wie die Grünen das so ein
bisschen gemacht haben was sie jetzt in
vier Jahren erreichen wollen ne oder ich
für jedes Jahr sich Ziele gesetzt haben
dann sieht man dass die immer und immer
und immer verfehlt werden
und damit berührten wir in die
zukünftigen Generation immer immer mehr
auf und ich es ist schon richtig
Deutschland gibt ja insgesamt über die
nächsten Jahre ungefähr eine Billion
alles zusammen genommen für die
Energiewende aus wenn wir das nicht
hinkriegen dann werden die Kosten für
die weiteren Generationen natürlich noch
sehr sehr viel größer werden weil da
jetzt nicht nur die Frage ist wo man die
erneuerbaren Energien produziert sondern
wie man mit den ganzen Schäden umgehen
soll und den ganzen anderen folgen die
im Zuge des Klimawandels eintreten es
gibt ja diesen diesen berühmten Satz ja
was ist teurer als den Klimawandel zu
bekämpfen ja nicht zu begrüßt richtig es
gibt aber es gibt gute Beispiele und
deswegen denke ich manchmal es geht
schon auch nach vorne Salzgitter z.B da
wird der Stahl gemacht im großen Stil
die die haben CO2 Ausstoß von 8
Millionen Tonnen jedes Jahr um das zu
speichern wolltest und Wald der wäre so
groß wie ganz schließlich Holstein ja
und die Technologie ist mittlerweile da
die werden das hinkriegen bis zum Jahr
2030 33 werden die es schaffen CO2
neutralen Stahl zu produzieren Klima
neutralen Stahl zu produzieren grünen
Stahl das ist doch eigentlich mal eine
ganz großartige Vision oder die Idee zum
Beispiel in der vor der Küste in der
Nordsee ja diesen riesigen Offshore
Windpark zu bauen jetzt eine Olaf Scholz
auch mit angekündigt neuen Staaten und
so weiter wollen das machen das ist
wirklich richtig groß ja bis 2050 werden
da 300 Gigawatt aus offshore Windenergie
erzeugt dass sie die ihren dabei
Luxemburg da ein schönes Luxemburg
Großbritannien und so weiter wie wir
Deutschland Belgien Niederlande
Frankreich alle dabei also das heißt
manchmal kriegen das auf eine
erstaunlich gute Art und Weise hin und
mein so langsam
ich will dass das eine
bild-zeitungsüberschrift wird was wir da
tolles machen ich finde die Beispiel
alle großartig aber das wäre super
gewesen das schon vor 10 Jahren
hingekriegt
wir haben ja immer noch das Gefühl mit
manchen Sachen können wir warten also
Tempolimit auf der Autobahn es wird
sicher irgendwann eingeführt ne
wahrscheinlich wird das dann noch
dramatisch viel weniger sein also was
man überhaupt noch fahren darf und so
weiter aber alles ebenso offener letzten
Drücker wenn man es eigentlich auch
sagen kann oder sonst kommt es
eigentlich auch darauf nicht mehr an ich
glaube wir sind im Augenblick auf der
Kippe zwischen noch mal alle
Anstrengungen zu machen die man irgendwo
machen kann mit der Konsequenz einer
sehr starken AFD
oder zu sagen okay dann sind wir halt
die letzte Generation die ein gutes
Leben hatte und wenn ich es nicht so
meinem Freundes und Bekanntenkreis
umhöre dann würde ich sagen so die
Haltung ist fifty fifty
und das hat sich enorm verändert
gegenüber vor fünf Jahren ja da kannte
ich niemanden der gesagt hat ja gut
jetzt ist sowieso zu spät was soll's
noch das heißt wir haben also ich habe
das ja von Anfang an mitverfolgt ne als
sozusagen grüner der ersten Stunde ja am
Anfang wurden diese Vorstellungen dass
man den großen ökologischen Umbau
braucht ja das wurde verlacht und dann
wurde es ewig bekämpft heute ist es
selbstverständlich aber heute sagen dann
die gleichen Leute die es vorher
verlacht haben und bekämpft haben ja
jetzt ist zu spät
und das ist so ein bisschen die Haltung
ich habe eine gewisse Angst davor dass
wir sich so in den nächsten Jahren die
Haltung durchsetzt geht sowieso nicht
weißt was ich glaube Richard
abschließend gesagt ich habe neulichen
ähm
schönes Stück über Vertrauen gelesen es
gibt ja ich glaube wir haben zu wenig
Vertrauen ich glaube uns ist als
Gesellschaft das Vertrauen abhanden
gekommen das Vertrauen in die
Institutionen das Vertrauen in die Leute
einer Spitze des vertrauen dass wir das
irgendwie geregelt kriegen und es
interessant ich es gibt ein ganz
berühmtes Experiment Harvard Professor
schon vorher als 40 Jahren der hat das
mal beschrieben Kontrollillusion ja die
eigentlich an an paradox ist ja also
sozusagen bei selbst bei objektiv und
kontrollierbaren Dingen ja
Virus ja wir wissen das nächste
Coronavirus oder ein anderes Virus wird
kommen Krieg es werden neue Kriege
kommen es werden Inflation kommen über
die Klimaveränderung reden wir gerade
die ganze Zeit und wir wünschen uns so
sehr ein wenig Kontrolle zu haben dass
wir uns ein reden sie tatsächlich auch
in Teilen zu haben und der hat in diesem
Experiment sehr interessant mal
nachgewiesen dass Leute die beim Lotto
spielen z.B ja die die Zahlen selber
auswählen schätzen Ihre Gewinnchancen
deutlich höher ein als wenn sie diese
Zahl einfach genannt kriegen und du
wirst ihm hat meine Zahl sagt fühl doch
einfach so so aus nein das Gefühl ist
wenn ich es selber mache dann habe ich
schon ganz gut wirklich ein bisschen
mehr Kontrolle Würfelspielen genauso ja
wenn du eine niedrige Zahl brauchst dann
wirst du diesen Würfel vorsichtiger als
wenn du eine höhere Zahl brauchst ja
weil du glaubst die Art und Weise wie du
diesen Würfel wirken wirst und zwar du
selber gibt dir sozusagen ein bisschen
Kontrolle zurück und du meinst das ist
in der Politik genau dasselbe ja ich
glaube die Leute das Gefühl hätten sie
könnten mitreden in all den Fragen sind
Sie sicher dass viel bessere
Entscheidungen gefällt werden ja ich ich
das ist das Gefühl dass wir haben
genauso nach dem Motto die Deppen da
oben die verstehen uns einfach nicht
mehr und wir haben es aber eigentlich
selber besser drauf ja wir wir versuchen
sozusagen die Kontrolle wieder zurück zu
erlangen überall diese Dinge und es gibt
ja diesen berühmten Satz ne vertrauen
ist gut Kontrolle ist besser und und der
Autor sagte da das ist ein guter Satz
aber auf die großen Fragen des Lebens
angewendet ist dieser Satz total falsch
und sagte die wirklich wichtig vielen
Dinge werden sich niemals kontrollieren
lassen wann wir sterben wen wir lieben
von wem wir geliebt werden und der will
darauf hinaus das Vertrauen sozusagen
der Kit in einer Gesellschaft ist und
Misstrauen ist ein wirklich zersetzendes
Gift ja und die Menschen wir leben in
einer misstrauensgruppe und wir Menschen
sind total darauf angewiesen ja
aneinander zu vertrauen weil ohne es war
der Fehler liegt können
schreibt er da wir hätten Angst wir
hätten das Gefühl gleich werden die vom
Bus überfahren oder was auch immer und
dieses dieses dieser
Kontrollverlust den wir versuchen Weg zu
machen den könnten wir ersetzen durch
mehr Vertrauen einfach darauf zu
vertrauen ist die die werden die Dinge
machen und es sind da draußen nicht nur
Typen unterwegs die uns alle nach dem
Leben trachten die alle unser Bestes
wollen nämlich nur unser Steuergeld ja
die alte nichts drauf haben die alle
Versager sind ich glaube wir brauchen
mehr wieder Vertrauen das ist uns
abhanden gekommen das ist glaube einer
der Schlüssel zu diesem ganzen Thema ja
also ich würde es schon zwei Seiten
sehen also einerseits finde ich ja ein
gesundes Misstrauen ja
auch ein gesundes Misstrauen gegenüber
der Politik nicht in Form einer
allgemeinen unfähigkeitserklärung genau
sondern vielleicht dass ich natürlich
bei bestimmten politischen Prozessen
sage diesen Politiker vertraue ich nicht
oder ich vertraue nicht darauf dass das
eine gute oder eine richtige Entwicklung
ist und dass sie da kritisch mündig bin
und nicht nicht alles glaube ne da sind
wir uns einig auf der anderen Seite ist
es ja so anders als Diktaturen die
brauchen keinen vertrauen die brauchen
Angst ne sind liberal demokratische
Gesellschaft noch vertrauen angewiesen
wenn man nicht mehr vertraut in einer
Gesellschaft dann funktioniert dauerhaft
eine Gesellschaft nicht mehr die auf
Freiheit aufgebaut ist das ist so und
nachdem beides den du da gerade
beschrieben hast also dass Menschen sich
selbst immer für großartige gehalten
der gehört natürlich dazu dass man das
irgendwie man instant denkt wenn man an
deren Stelle wäre dann würde man schon
alles richtig machen und würde alles
besser machen und ich glaube wenn man
nur drei Tage in so einem Ministerium
wäre dann würde man sofort begreifen ja
dass das nicht so ist dass man als
Minister einen Tanker hat mit hunderten
manchmal tausenden von Mitarbeitern und
die man erstmal gar nicht kennt und ihm
erstmal verstehen muss und da muss man
die ganzen menschlichen Rente und dann
Kühne und macht Interessen und so also
das ist ja so ein Wirtschaftsministerium
oder gerade so ein super Ministerium ist
ja eigentlich viel zu groß ist
eigentlich gar nicht mehr führbar und
dass man man ist ein sehr erheblichen
Teil der Zeit allein nur mit solchen
Aufgaben ja im Grunde genommen in
Anspruch genommen sonst fällt man über
seine eigenen Leute oder das was man
macht wird dann wird ausgebremst und
also man macht sich gar keine
Vorstellung mit welchen sorgen ja sich
ein Minister noch alles rumplagen muss
außer mit diesen tatsächlichen
fachlichen Entscheidung
dann kommen die ganzen Lobby Interessen
die dann eine Rolle spielen an denen man
oft auch gar nicht komplett vorbei gehen
kann
mit ihren 800.000 Arbeitsplätzen und und
und das muss man alles miteinander
abwägen und danach irgendwie mit
grundsätzlichen oder prinzipiellen
Entscheidungen zusammenzubringen das ist
unglaublich schwierig und der
überschätzt man natürlich selber wenn
man von außen kritisiert wie einfach das
doch wäre das alles so das ist auf jeden
Fall so
dass man gewisses Grundvertrauen haben
soll in das Funktionieren der Demokratie
und dass man nicht ausnahmslos von
Idioten regiert wird ist eine wichtige
Geschichte ja finde ich aber die Frage
was ist sozusagen der richtige Weg
zwischen einer grundsätzlichen
misstrauenserklärung in die Politik auf
der einen Seite ja und einem düsigen
vertrauen dass die Dinge schon richtig
laufen das muss ja jeder in einem sehr
komplizierten Prozess der
urteilsschulung für sich selbst
irgendwie überlegen und dafür braucht
man eine Menge Zeit und muss man sehr
trainiert sein über sich und das Leben
nachzudenken und das kann in einer
Demokratie nicht vorausgesetzt werden
das heißt du hast auch einfach eine
große Anzahl von Bevölkerung die in
ihren politischen Überzeugungen großen
Wert auf schnelle Lösungen legen in
ihrem Kopf ja und nicht aus sorgfältige
Abwägung von solchen Prozessen und das
einzige was man da sagen kann und da
sind wir wieder am Anfang der Sendung
wenn wir eine Medienlandschaft haben die
das Misstrauen bis geht nicht mehr
anreizt dass der Punkt und umgekehrt für
das Vertrauen eigentlich gar nichts mehr
liefert das ist genau der Punkt dann
wird es schwierig das ist genau der
Punkt Richard und ich finde darüber
sollten wir bei anderen Gelegenheit noch
mal nachdenken und diesen diesen
Gedanken irgendwie weitertragen und ich
merke es auch im Hintergrundgespräch
auch mit Kolleginnen mit Kollegen die
häufig auch bei uns in der Sendung zu
Gast sind das ist etwas das treibt die
irgendwie alle um wie alle merken dass
wir da an so einem Punkt sind wo es
entweder in die eine oder eine andere
Richtung kippen kann und es ist auch
wirklich Teil unserer Verantwortung
zuzusehen dass es in die richtige
Richtung geht und nicht in die falsche
und die Diskussion glaube ich das stimmt
gerade am Anfang die die man weiß ja
Medien und Selbstkritik das ist so eine
Sache da können sich ein bisschen
Kompetenz möchte
auch sagen dass du gesagt hast also wir
sind noch nicht mal im
vorschulkindergarten wenn es darum geht
als Medien schaffen oder innerhalb des
Mediensystems
selbstkritisch zu sein und Kritik gut zu
ertragen zu vertragen also Richard danke
sehr interessante Austausch hat eine
gute Woche
bis dann
mach's gut tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und
potstars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]